he's a Swedish video game programmer and
designer he co-founded the video game
company that created minecraft in 2010
he has an estimated net worth of 1.5
billion dollars
he's Markus notch Persson and here are
his top ten rules for success can you
tell us a little bit about how you got
started in video game development oh
well I was really really young like
eight years old my dad got us a
Commodore 128 and we started subscribe
to a magazine that had like code
listings for games and I thought I am
doing them and start pointing with them
some of it's been with me for a long
time it's kind of gradually been growing
and then it became a profession and then
I quit that job and started and we just
went in there and can you what advice
would you give to people who want to get
started in video game development
themselves well yeah look at what other
people have done look at tutorials look
at code and just play with the code and
then once you're comfortable with it
don't try to make your biggest game just
make the small game and actually finish
it I've been playing games for ever
number programmers this was eight so
obviously have some kind of experience
in it and I kind of I can understand
kinda what's fun gameplay but I didn't
mean to make my kind of big success to
claim that I know the secret sauce would
be kind of false a formula but I wasn't
following for me I was trying to make a
game well I think actually working on it
is more important than thinking about it
so if you just get started even if it's
not something big even if you are small
just try to make games or look at
tutorials or play with code other people
are made or something and then also to
keep a critical eye towards what you're
doing because it's very easy to just
assume what you're doing is good because
you're used to it but if you try to see
it with like the eyes of a new player it
helps a lot I think that the best advice
I could give everyone is totally into
advice but if you are going to listen to
advice then making sure you actually do
something is a good advice if you just
sit around planning something and not
doing it you're not actually going to
get anywhere
you sold your company recently to
Microsoft but you haven't really been
talking about it
so what happened there I wasn't working
on minecraft anymore and I had him for a
long time but I still was kind of
responsible for it since I made it there
was the main shareholder of mojang and
then this big thing happen with the ulay
incident with people fatemeh changed the
rules in like did any relicensing yeah
right which had always been in place but
what actually happened was that some
people brought it up like so we're not
allowed to do this and that oh is that
no so we looked it over and actually
made the rules more lenient but people
still get very upset with like me
personally even though I wasn't even
working with anymore I just figured like
I don't know if I want to put up with
this anymore
and then I saw that this is phil fish
video this is a do two documentary about
a guy called phil fish Alec talks about
them how like internet personalities and
like famous people people aren't really
they're not talking to that actual
person when a talkative person if I'm
talking about the ID of that person have
this disconnect when you respond
personally to stuff that's not really
intended to be personal and I can't just
figured like I'd probably maybe I don't
have to put up with this so just when
that happened and that everyone's giving
me something like crap online and just
went no this is not worse than work
right so just waited kind of jokingly
like you who wants to buy the company
right when a couple of days later call
the CEO it came by said we got a bunch
of offers like were you serious yeah and
I fall about for a while and said yeah
maybe it's time how do you run your
minecraft company have you sold out to
the evil corporations yet no not yet
that we hope not to but how long do you
think be able to do that before you kind
of get absorbed by the Borg
I think that depends on how long we can
I keep the fun mood going in that we
have it's very stressful I didn't really
got to me I didn't want to work on the
project anymore
as I wanted to just write prototypes or
new games it's not that the stuff I
actually get happy from doing and I felt
like stealing I needed to be responsible
for it because I was still like the main
owner of the company and there was me or
developed a game and people were like
looking up to me and for me was very
important to make sure that it was like
a clean break like it wasn't like trying
to like get some investor and try to
grow the company there like a big exit
was more about getting it quick and easy
and just get it done with I think the
difference there is kind of people who
do something as their job and master
hobby you get so much more experience so
much faster so you can kind of skip a
few of the steps I think I think it's
very important now you know even be an
expert right off the bat you have to
because I've reprogrammed this was eight
and I'm far from an expert stale and
it's like you can't expect the first
fingers do to be a hit so having a few
jobs is just probably a good idea
because before King I didn't know how to
finish games so that was a jutsu
experience with me yeah but since the
deal as a hobby as well I can get to
learn faster than just doing its job oh
yeah letting other people into the code
that was really scary jazz is the guy
now working Minecraft with me
hey one change I've made is that the
spiders for the kinds of walls use an
atrophy yeah now T they are always
another okay so if they hit a key yeah
that's a really clever act every every
time you change stuff somebody is going
to say that it's better for some
grenades
oh this much better but most of the time
you you have to like focus on what you
feel what you feeling yourself if it's
good or bad another thing a suggestion
is to make a scarecrow because it would
be so fun because they have like a
pumpkin here yeah and that's all cloth -
nothing sticks very very cute or the hay
in the middle oh yeah hey boss maybe if
you use like a target number for the
creepers yeah we would attract monsters
yes and we should have snowmen as well
that's the throw snowballs
it's like you when I see like
suggestions from the community and then
I try not to add it because it feels
like I'm doing like give just a just ask
for things that I Adam and it's not
necessarily my yeah my like idea that's
driving it anymore but that's changing
now because gels is adding stuff that
they fix works but well when I see it
actually in the game and it makes sense
I kind of was much easy just accepted it
was a it worked a lot better than I
thought it would I think it's it's a
matter just letting go I think because
it's it's good for the game but I the
trap clock was just brilliant mmm yeah
right now it's really fun to add stuff
to my preference say it's also fun to be
part of this so early early and really
be with the core team I mean I don't
know how big we're going to be in future
but it's fun to be from from almost the
beginning I have been working on like
prototypes and trying to learn your
languages but it's not really the intent
that I'm going to finish a game maybe I
will at some point and then it's good to
have like come to set up for it and it's
it's fun to have like the idea when you
work in a stuff like it's supposed to
become something but not feel like fresh
like it has to so you could possibly
never release the game again yeah that I
would be fine with that it was a long
time when I was freaking out like how do
I follow up a Minecraft it was really
hard to deal with like yeah because it's
the entire like big like cultural
phenomena you can manufacture that maybe
now that I've analyzed it understand
some of white minecraft work right but
that only means I know how minecraft
worked back in time when the context was
made in right it doesn't mean I know how
to do it again I kind of feel like I
made a game and then the community kind
of made the community around the game
and the communication the combination of
two is kind of their true minecraft so
it's way more than just that the game I
made about just shopping Rock kind of
slowly because for example creative mode
it's not what I wanted in the game at
all but it's in the game because a lot
of people use it and then the people
doing really cool mods in the room to
really interpret stuff like abusing bugs
in red stones so we can
set and it's turned into something much
bigger and it's very impressive and it's
very fun to be able to be part of that
yeah I think was like really young and
said I want to be a cop or something
but I kind of always knew that I wanted
to make games and I said so in school to
my like career counselor thing and she
said well that's probably not gonna
happen
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Zed ski asked me
to so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next leave
it in the comments below and I'll see
what I can do
I'd also love to know which of the top
ten rules have the biggest impact on you
leave it in the comments and I will join
the discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon